yeah i'm afraid it's quite uh bad news
the uh we were due to get the state of
the economy gross domestic products and
how much it's expanding or contracting
by this is the best measure of just how
well we are doing you know it's a
measure of how much income has been
generated across the economy uh the
previous month which is say march those
previous figures we had showed a
contraction of 0.1 percent well the
latest figures show a contraction of 0.3
let me just show it to you
on this chart here here you can see it
there was mind there's 0.1
in march uh in april it's down by 0.3
percent so a contraction it's actually
worse than economists had expected they
thought that perhaps it might be a
little bit of an increase but this just
underlines those concerns a lot of
people have that the economy might now
be heading towards if not a recession
then certainly a period of contraction
or stagnation remember the oecd the that
big organization uh looking at economics
they said that the uk would face the
weakest growth in any developed economy
next year and might face a potential
period of basically flatlining well this
is showing that we're already seeing
some fall in the amount of income we're
generating across the economy and
economists will be concerned about it
because obviously it comes amid many
concerns about the cost of living it
comes with households being severely
pressed uh by higher costs of energy and
of course with businesses across the
country struggling uh to satisfy uh to
try and actually kind of generate the
demand they that they need to try and
keep this bounce back in the economy
going so that is a cause for genuine
concern the numbers just out from the
office for national statistics and as i
say worse than expected there have been
an expectation that the economy would
actually expand in the month of april
but these monthly numbers suggesting
that it contracted by 0.3 and as you can
see it is the biggest contraction it
looks like since
uh december in terms of monthly uh
numbers for gdp so a bit of a
disappointment there
to to put it mildly so what then are the
tools at the treasury's disposal at the
prime minister's disposal to try and do
something about this in the short term
well i mean in short you know the the
government has already
put a lot of uh fuel into in there
they've they have announced that they
are going to be uh subsidizing energy
bills to the tune of 400 pounds that's
obviously coming on later in uh in the
year uh they've also uh
produced extra money that's going into
people's council taxes as well so you've
you have government stimulus coming
through
but the reality is there is a big
fall-off in demand at the moment and
it's it's it's a uk story in particular
uh but to some extent we are seeing
something like this elsewhere around the
world uh as well many other economies
are starting to weaken perhaps not
necessarily as as quickly as the uk
but nonetheless you're seeing the same
thing and why is this it's because we
have a massive energy price shock right
now energy prices have gone through the
roof and as a result of that that's
something that we will notice obviously
in our household bills but companies
around the country notice it as well
because everyone has to one way or
another pay for energy and that is
basically causing or helping contributes
uh to this you've had really strong
growth uh just last year uh in these
months last year but now look at the
where we are at the moment two con
successive months uh worth of
contraction it's not quite in recession
territory uh yet because we need to
actually get the quarterly numbers so
when people talk about recessions they
tend to mean two successive quarters of
contraction we're talking about months
so we're yet to get the rest of the
months uh in the current quarter we're
in at the moment we need a couple more
months for that but if that continues
obviously then we're talking about a
quarter of contraction and then that's
one step closer to a recession one just
a little bit of detail because this is
data that's just come in literally a few
minutes ago uh in terms of what's
contributing to it
services so you know that's the main
part of the economy 80
uh that is the main thing falling by 0.3
but we'll bring you more data and more
detail on this as we have it as i say
disappointing news that the economy
is falling at the moment